et maintenant si j'étais président plein
non mais
voici les victimes
elodie gossuin bonsoir sa sortie je
crois qu'il faut dire elodie gossuin
chouraqui
la vraie révélation c'est qu'en fait
cette coupe va tout le monde croyait que
ça ne parlait pas alors ça va tout le
monde j'aurais eu du très bien le dis
que je suis un mètre 78 80 kw à 80 91 et
grandit donc 85 85 cm de tour de
poitrine 90 minutes 88 chacun tient son
bonnet e au fond sonore 105 madame s est
pas exactement les mensurations c'est
moins 85
non c'est pas un peu plus un peu plus
combien 97e tour de taille 70 à 60 et
hanches 90g 86 qu'est ce qui s'est passé
est là près du cul ça arrive aux
meilleurs
la vie laurent tu sais qu'elodie gossuin
et conseillère générale de rien
conseiller régional de picardie et qu'il
faut faire attention à la picardie banon
fait peur maintenant c'est que vous êtes
une élue maintenant oui je suis très
fier de l'être
ouais bon dernier
alors l'histoire d'elodie gossuin qui
monde la connaît d'abord reine du muguet
à compiègne c'est comme ça que tout a
commencé en scène fignon à melwood
ensuite progression inexorable mais
certaines zones humides et cet homme et
ventriloque
ce ne sont pas mes vannes ensuite me
choisit gouvieux ensuite miss picardie
ensuite miss france miss europe mais pas
miss univers puisque à l'élection à
porto rico
un quotidien de san juan la capitale de
porto rico comme vous le savez avait
annoncé que vous étiez un homme qui
tient juste on l'a dit souvent et c'est
la vie est injuste c'est un truc qui en
fait qui était sur internet c'est un
site internet c'est le fameux site
internet où on disait que jean luc
delarue avait deux pénis
non mais c'est vrai alors que je vais
pas vrai c'est là je pense pas mais
voilà alors enfin malgré tout ça était
5e dauphine à miss univers c'est déjà
pas mal parce que bah oui c'est grand
l'univers voilà alors c'est un peu comme
en picardie vous n'avez pas été élu mais
vous êtes quand même cinquième sur la
liste de classe 5e dauphine de gilles de
robien en quelque sorte toujours
cinquième dauphine bon ben voilà alors
que vous êtes devenue conseillère
régionale ça vous a déçu de pas avoir de
dia des mélodies n'ont absolument pas
c'était tout autre chose avait aucun
rapport bien sûr avec toutes les
élections de miss
c'était un autre engagement et notre
motivé parce que je me sens profondément
picarde c'était plus pour ma région
pas pour un parti même jour un pour un
homme pour siceco être car je me rends
pas compte toi parce que moi j'ai
toujours grandi dans cette région et
j'adore cette richesse bien cette région
c'est beau car 10 en décembre
9h20 à des envies de mort violente et
c'est la petite venise
ouais voilà gilles de robien vous
demandez défilent en maillot de non pas
du tout il a beaucoup de respect pour
gilles de robien non plus aux barrages
alors finalement la politique c'est pas
tellement différent de miss france nom
d'une certaine je pense que la vie de
nice m'a préparé à la vie j'ai toujours
pour la paix dans le monde comme quand
vous étiez nice jamais déclarer sa
question dit toujours que c'est mal de
tuer des animaux pour faire des manteaux
n'a bien sûr on vous demande toujours de
sourire toute la journée comme quand
vous étiez mis finalement c'est assez
naturel qu'on m'a jamais dit de le faire
or la droite bon ben c'est fait bananer
je crois que c'est terrible ce qui s'est
passé on a parlé d'un 21 avril à
l'envers
mais c'est sûr que c'est dommage parce
que je pense effectivement que les gens
n'ont pas faire votre régionales dans
certaines régions je suis d'accord
effectivement qu'en fonction des
attentes des gens je pense que peut-être
pas de responsabilité dans ces résultats
si moi je pense que oui parce que vous
n'avez pas vraiment aidé la droite
devait déclarer elodie gossuin que
ségolène royal ou l'admirent y est
profondément que c'était une femme
politique que vous admiriez le plus j'ai
dit que c'était une femme que j'admire
énormément et je ne regrette pas ce que
j'ai dit c'est bien gentil mais la
droite se met à dire que l'école un
réseau sont bien je suis d'accord j'ai
23 ans et bien sûr que je rêve d'avoir
une vie comme la sienne aussi pas nous y
dormirons trop longue et une victoire
aux bordelais monde s'est pas forcé
chiant d'avoir une vie de femme aussi
épanouie klaas-jan bien sûr que moi 23
ans est ce que je rêve d'une vie de
femme épanouie oui je pense oui
avoir quatre enfants pour moi déjà
qu'elle voit là bas mais françois
hollande je parle français mais c'est
sur le lit et c'est france 3 qui pensent
qu'il faut maintenant c'est que vous
vous dites que ségolène royal est une
fille formidable
geneviève de fontenay elle dit qu'il
faut voter pour avec la guinée donc à la
respectivement vous aidez pas beaucoup
la droite l'a quand même hein mais je en
aucun cas j'ai soutenu geneviève dans
tout l'est tous les crocos les
interviews qu'elle a pu donner avant moi
ma candidature j'ai jamais dit que
j'étais parce que j'ai deux comités miss
france que j'avais même opinion qu'un
cas est ce que vous croyez que la france
a besoin d'un retour de jospin vous
croyez que hollande sera un bon premier
ministre
je ne pense pas vous croyez que les 35
heures finalement c'est vachement bien
c'est assez mitigé j'ai une opinion
assez mitigée sur les 35 heures je pense
qu'il ya du positif quand même la bêta
tu rentre trop dans le détail ce qu'on
pourrait un peu plus léger ce qui
confère au conseil général c'est qui
aura le bouton oui le bouton non et puis
je tombe je sais pas au milieu de cette
non ont facilité la tâche peut-être
peut-être qu'on va être obligé de faire
beaucoup et 43 c'est cuit avant même de
commencer dirait passage journée espoir
mais effectivement on recommence un peu
avec les mêmes mais moi je suis très
fier que gilles de robien garder son
ministère parce que c'est un homme
formidable
à part ça donc j'ai bientôt publier un
livre sur votre aventure miss france
miss europe chez michel lafon qui
s'appelle aventure érotique d'une
coquine libertine
non j'ai la [ __ ] au diadème avant
moi j'avais les aventures aussi sérieuse
si vous avez raconté ça les histoires
d'amour d'une miss france non absolument
pas je parle de mon rêve de miss france
et miss europe
est ce que j'ai vécu pendant l'année ce
que moi j'ai vécu c'est vraiment mon
rêve à moi je voulais faire un disque
aussi
bah si c'est bien prévu c'est pas prévu
bon bah je vais faire un aussi bien ne
puisse pas donc c'est bien mais pas
faire déjà dit j'ai pas faire un disque
qui sa famille et une proposition mais
pour l'instant cela pourrait vous le
faites pas parce que je peux pas tout
faire en même temps et passionné que les
auditionner bien la chanson est très
belle c'est un rêve aussi pour plus tard
effectivement quand vous serez ministre
j
soyez bien chanteuse aussi en fait
j'avais beaucoup trop de qualités
finalement poète miss france pour être
miss poitau et puis à la ferme aussi la
ferme des célébrités sur tf1 veut y
aller je ne sais pas j'ai été contacté
mais pourquoi vous vous hésité parce que
j'ai effectivement la priorité juin
d'être élu conseiller régional et pour
moi c'est l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est
bien payé quand même hein effectivement
mais bon j'ai jamais été attirés que par
l'argent
elle a surtout été tirée dans la caisse
mais j'ai effectivement un berger pas de
problème d'argent j'ai la chance de voir
faire des choix par rapport à ce qui me
correspond vraiment j'ai pas le choix de
l'argent facile je fais le choix de deux
du domaine dans lequel je m'épanouis
quand manière générale mais s'il voulait
se mener votre caniche
je sais pas c'est d'être alors alors on
revient là il pas un truc de
prostitution bizarre cette histoire on
revient à la politique devant l'ampleur
de la crise que traverse notre pays on a
besoin de toutes les bonnes volontés
donc on va faire le digg sua une
interview au boulot